wir stehen vor allem der härtesten
Winter in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten
Robert Habeck hat selber eingeräumt jede
Kilowattstunde zählt und das kann man
nur unterstützen allerdings
unterscheidet sich diese Aussage vom
Handeln der Ampelkoalition denn mitten
in diesem Herbst und vor dem härtesten
Winter seit vielen vielen Jahren möchte
die Ampelkoalition die Kernkraftwerke in
Deutschland abschalten das ist
unverantwortlich und wird dazu führen
dass die Strom- und Energiepreise weiter
steigen daher mein Plädoyer Herr Habeck
herr Scholz stoppen Sie diesen Irrsinn
verlängern Sie die Laufzeiten der
Kernkraftwerke polit in Parteien ticken
anders Herr Habig weiß ganz genau die
Niedersachsen war es entscheidend für
das Überleben seiner Partei zumindest
ist kurzfristig und deswegen ist völlig
irrelevant was ein Bürger denkt was die
Wirtschaft denkt es ist nur wichtig was
die Partei den